we had this from The Daily Mail
exclusive Trump will not be arraigned
this week former president is expected
to be indicted tomorrow and Secret
Service will make plans for his
surrender and appearance in New York
Court next week a source familiar with
the proceedings exclusively told
dailymail.com on Tuesday there will be
no arraignment this week he's expected
to be indicted Wednesday after which the
DA's office will reach out to his secret
service detail to make arrangements for
his surrender all 36 000 NYPD officers
are in uniform and on notice for
deployment after Trump called for
supporters to protest his imminent
indictment now the question is
will there be a perp walk
if that question is for me I will tell
you that Alvin Bragg he's the Manhattan
D.A going after Trump he doesn't like
Trump it's quite clear he despises the
man he's trying to damage the the former
president I think maybe uh this Mr uh
Alvin Bragg wants to be the governor
maybe one day but he's going after Trump
uh I think it's going to backfire the
perp walk wouldn't surprise me I think
they're going to have to figure out how
that's going to work with the Secret
Service uh I ran a County Jail a big
jail you can't just get Donald Trump and
put him in a holding cell and general
population you ain't going to do any of
that I believe that there will be a
booking photo though I believe that's
going to happen to place the uh the
president United States former president
handcuffs you just don't do it
especially for a a misdemeanor crime
like this which is going through an
indictment I I can't figure that one out
but it's it's not a well a violent crime
team that's right I got a book on it so
no I think he's going to do it it's all
about Donald Trump for 2024 that's what
this is it's about 2024 keeping them off
the ballot trying to this has never
happened before a former president being
arrested so so what they they they book
him and as they're bringing him in the
Secret Service is with him the whole
time whole time he's in the temporary
holding cell awaiting processing and
he's got two Secret Service guys with
him then they bring him to general
population at the county or local jail
or it's Manhattan so I think that's on
um what street is that on I can't
remember what street but it's a lower uh
Lower Manhattan so he's going to be
inside there in the South with a bunch
of other guys and the Secret Service
guards are going to be standing in front
of him in the jail with him
there's just no way there's no
logistical way that that would happen I
mean are they also going to inspect the
Secret Service members and put them in
handcuffs like it doesn't it doesn't
make any sense and then the camera
stopped working and the guards fall
asleep
I imagine the secret service is not
going to surrender their sidearms I
imagine that the president will be
as I mean he's he's the foreign
president you know they're the the same
protocol is going to apply for him going
to be booked uh as for anything else I
think that it's pretty clear that this
isn't he's not going to go to jail for
this like I I don't imagine that it's
that this is even a jailable offense
it's like a 500 fine yeah so this is
this is all just and it's and yeah
here's the crazy thing the the charge is
basically bad bookkeeping so here's
here's here's what happens they're
saying that the money he paid to Stormy
Daniels was because uh he was paying her
off and then he listed it as legal fees
and that's a crime so he's going to get
charged or whatever it's like when when
when you're filing your taxes or
whatever you're doing your accounting if
you mislabel something do you know what
happens they call you up on the phone or
they show up and knock on your door or
get a letter typically you get a letter
I don't think they call you at all yeah
you'll get a letter and it'll say we
believe this was an error you owe us X
dollars and then you respond with okay
that that's it yeah well the doj uh they
declined uh to prosecute Trump on this
deal with with stormy so I think they
went after Michael Cohen obviously uh
Trump's attorney back then so Michael
Kerwin obviously got three years in
prison related to things with with
Russia collusion stuff so no I I will
say this uh Donald Trump is going to
drive into this sally port he's going to
go into a processing room they probably
are going to fingerprint him but they're
not going to wipe it on his hands it's
all done electronically he'll never
reach a jail cell they'll take a picture
of him and he'll be out the door within
45 minutes it'll be the best thing for
him I think Trump uh if Trump was smart
I'm imagining that right now with his
campaign staff he's saying please
everybody your thoughts and prayers that
they arrest me tomorrow or next week
please please everybody cross your
fingers send your thoughts and prayers
that I do get arrested it's going to be
the biggest thing for for Trump
supporters it's going to pull the it's
going to take the wind out of the sails
of the left yay you did it Trump's been
arrested have a nice day it's done it's
over and for everyone everyone who
supports Trump or even people in the
middle it's going to be hey look they're
trying to arrest their political rival
or they're trying to use the weight of
criminal law enforcement to stop their
principal political rival I don't see
how any how you could characterize it in
any other way it's an obvious
political stunt it's it's an attempt for
the Democratic party the Democrats to go
after Donald Trump yeah all it's going
to do is show middle American voters who
supported Trump that if if Trump can be
arrested then the Democrats can bring
the weight of law against you right it
reminds people how vulnerable they are
especially if they're in counties where
the D.A or you know any part of the
judicial system is left and has been
elected I mean it shows you that they
are not willing to draw like if they
aren't willing to draw the line at the
former president what would stop them
from persecuting you yeah there's
nothing I don't think that there's I
don't think that this is is a situation
where Trump is going to be it's not
going to make your average middle of the
road uh voter more sympathetic to Trump
uh it's definitely going to Galvanize
the base it might get some people on the
edges but I don't see how it's going to
change a lot of people's minds it it
it's it's going to have a positive
impact for Donald Trump on Independent
independent voters okay so what there's
an article in Politico and it's like
don't overthink it an arrest for Trump
is bad and I'm just like these people
are so stupid they are the stupidest
people ever in corporate press the
Democratic party they don't know that
there's no such thing as bad press Trump
capitalized on bad press in 2015 and 16
to get elected the media wouldn't shut
about him everything was negative and he
won they seem to think that this
political article said he will not earn
a single new voter and that's the most
that's the stupidest thing possible yeah
he's not going to lose a single voter
and the worst case scenario is he
doesn't get any voters but the likely
scenario is someone will see Trump on
the TV again and be like oh yeah I'm
gonna vote for Trump so I'm on TV don't
even know what happened
I don't think he I don't think he loses
I don't think he loses a single vote
over this no no but he's going to gain
votes yeah this is what people don't get
these these Democrats we we had the
krakensteins on these liberal pundits
and they said they thought the economy
was pretty good or or good and I'm like
that makes sense if you look at the
polling liberals think the economy is
good it's this it's the stupidest thing
I've ever heard by no objective standard
is the economy doing well but they think
it is okay that's the same thing with
Trump being arrested regular people who
don't care all that much are seeing this
and going just stop already man I'm
gonna vote for the guy to spite now
because people won't shut them up
well nobody knew who Alvin Breg was
until this story came out so his name is
probably Ben used and talked about more
in the last 24 hours than anybody in
America I didn't and I'm I'm fairly well
versed on who's who he's going to be the
guy that says I was the one to
accomplish this many many people have
wanted to see Donald Trump in either
handcuffs or arrested because they feel
he's a criminal he's the one able to get
it done he'll be looked at it here with
the far left nut jobs and everybody over
there and uh I I think it's shameful I
think it's abusive office I just saw a
little tweet or something that Rand Paul
put out there said we ought to be
arresting Alvin Bragg for abusing his
office and abusing his power but I think
this helps Donald Trump this is a
two-way race between he and DeSantis and
quite honestly desantis's comments the
other day when he had an opportunity to
speak about it he failed miserably
agreed yeah we talked about it I like
that he called out the Soros D.A and
said they're bad
but then he just said and I get involved
when he should have said you dare not
step one foot on Floridian soil to try
and take Donald Trump he will not be
extradited and we will use Force to stop
you that's what he should have said
and we mentioned the other day Carrie
like would have said it or something to
that effect
I don't see why he didn't say it right
like I know that because he wants to be
president yeah but even then if he
really thinks he has a chance to face
off against Trump that would have
potentially won the hearts of Trump's
base right saying like yeah we're going
to defend Trump like what's happening is
an abusive power would have benefited
him if he was serious about trying to
run stops I don't think anyone really
thinks DeSantis is going to beat Trump
everyone's just so scared and that's
what I I said the other day I'm just so
pissed off everyone is so scared sitting
there cowering worried about what's
going to happen it's like the only
reason the bad things are happening is
because good men do nothing that's it so
DeSantis he gets like a c-minus you know
it was a c minus statement ah yeah he
called out Soros Diaz they're garbage
you know Soros is a bad dude he's
putting in people who are letting
criminals go it's like the villains from
DC comic books but he really didn't make
a strong statement on on defending Trump
Hannah I think that uh uh Donald Trump
is in desantis's head every day he's
living in his head I felt it as comments
are irresponsible number one he never
mentioned Trump once in his what 90
seconds what he did make very clear is
most of the American people probably
have no clue or would have any clue why
Donald Trump was indicted by this
Manhattan D.A
but DeSantis made it very clear what did
he say and I said shame on him for
saying he said you know I don't know you
know how this this porn star stuff and
hush money works that's what he said and
that was a low jab and when when you
think about Ron DeSantis you know when
Trump was kind of attacking him for the
past several months and and then Santa
says I'm going to stay above The Fray
I'm not gonna I got a state to run I'm
not going to get in the name calling
this and that he just violated what he
said he wouldn't he would never do and
shame on him it's good it's he's done
he's done DeSantis is done and he
accidentally I hope accidentally said
I'm happy I'm the only one who removed
osoros D.A and I'm like you're happy
you're the only one shouldn't you be
saying I'm I'm upset I'm the only one
who did it like we should be why am I
the only one yes not being glad you're
the only one who's doing it uh yeah this
was a was a was a big
net negative in my opinion for DeSantis
he had he had a strong opportunity to uh
be to take the lead he didn't take it
I think I think his whether it's the
Paul Ryan's and the others that are
around him given him a bad advice but
listen obviously he's a great Governor
he's done a great job in Florida I think
he has a bright future he's he he has to
run in 2024 because he could lose his
Shine by 2028. so he really doesn't have
much of a choice but he's got one guy in
the way and that's the leader of our
party and that's not a blade Trump he
needs to apologize to Trump call Trump
up and say I'm sorry don't jump in the
race because he hasn't announced yet say
Donald Trump I'd love to be your running
mate let's go out there and save this
great country from the radical left and
DeSantis could be the president 2028.
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time